whether your financial goal is getting
out of debt saving for retirement or
starting your own business you'll be
facing as many pitfalls and obstacles as
a dungeon-crawling treasure seeker but
no hero has to go it alone
Frodo had the fellowship Harry had Ron
and Hermione eleven had the Hawkins
middle AV Club so if you want to slay
your money monsters you may want to
assemble a financial fellowship of your
own each financial dream team will be a
little different depending on your needs
but here are some of the most important
roles you might want to fill before
embarking into the great unknown
[Music]
plotting a course through the tax code
can be as confusing as charting a path
through the Dead Marshes a recent study
shows that while 34 percent of tax
filers choose to use a digital tool like
TurboTax to self file 28 percent use an
accountant so do you need one if your
financial situation is uncomplicated
such as a w-2 job with a set salary
you'll probably be just fine with a
digital tax filing service but if your
financial year was full of twists and
turns like running a small business
helping a child with tuition or owning a
rental property you should probably
consider partnering with an enrolled
agent or certified public accountant and
EA
can help you file your tax return while
a CPA is required to have a
comprehensive knowledge of taxes
auditing and business law if an expert
navigator can help you avoid even one
wrong turn
they might easily save you thousands of
dollars
nobody likes paying for the insurance
but think of it like stocking up on
armor or healing potions you hope to
never use you will be thanking your
lucky stars if life ends up throwing you
a nasty curveball like a disability or a
house fire a licensed insurance agent
may specialize in protecting against
bodily risks material damage or the
threat of a lawsuit
remember that agents are paid by
Commission typically 8 to 16 percent in
the US so be wary of any upsells an
independent insurance agent will allow
you to shop around for multiple policies
and compare prices and benefits this
situation calls for a master of the
mystical arts somebody that speaks the
arcane language legalese we need a
lawyer a trusted attorney can help you
craft magic scrolls
I mean contracts or wills set up a
business entity and back you up in a
tight legal situation and knowing just
one attorney will often give you access
to their database of other attorneys
just ask and odds are you'll get another
great specialist for your situation ever
wish you had a wise old expert to nudge
you in the right direction then maybe
it's time you sought out a professional
mentor you want someone that's been in
your shoes before it might be somebody
that graduated from your master's
program or that launched a business like
yours let them know how much you admire
them and ask if they'd let you take them
to breakfast once per month you might be
surprised by what people will do for a
chance to share their story
who's going to wrangle all the experts
you're recruiting that's where the
financial planner comes in
while some financial planners primarily
focus on investments and money
management a true captain of your team
should take a holistic view of your
finances and be able to command all the
moving parts the CFP is the premier
certification for financial advisors and
its bearer is often called the master
generalist their knowledge often runs
more broad than deep from retirement to
investments estate planning to insurance
they can help you make sure all the
pieces of your party are aiming for the
same
goals financial planners can be
compensated one of three ways Commission
for recommending financial products a
fee flack or percentage of your
investments or a hybrid of both also
known as fee based whatever you choose
make certain our financial advisor is a
sworn fiduciary who will put your
financial needs over their own unlike
Frodo's fellowship these companions
won't follow you for nothing most of
them will need to be paid but the
shortcuts they'll find and the traps
I'll disarm will save you money in the
long run best of all you'll have the
peace of mind knowing that somebody's
got your back and that may be what makes
all the difference and that's our two
cents monstrum is a fascinating new show
from PBS Digital Studios about monsters
myth and lore hosted by dr. Emily szarka
aka dr. Z the show delves into the
origins of iconic monsters and what
these creatures say about us want to
know more about the Nordic zombies that
may have inspired Game of Thrones White
Walkers or why the headless horseman was
well headless head to the link in the
description and subscribe to monstrum if
you've ever recruited a financial expert
for your team how did you go about it
let us know in the comments
you
[Music]